brace yourselves we're about to get into
some serious detail about telephone
systems I'm at the Museum of
communications in Seattle
to answer a question in old Hollywood
films when someone is on a phone call
and they get hung up on why did they
hear a dial tone well you can stick your
worldly plan up your well-made ass
supervision is the word that describes
how a telephone switch knows whether the
calling and called parties are on hook
or off hook when you end a call and hang
up the equipment receives that on hook
signal and anything that was in service
at that time disconnects and goes back
to its normal state so you end up with
dead air now the reason that a sound
director would use a dial tone instead
of just nothing is kind of obvious right
it's to make it clear that the other
side is hung up that's certainly what
lots of people argue online except they
could just do that using one short sound
effect and sometimes they do don't ever
call me again Wow I guess you're home
good luck
it turns out there's another reason back
in the days of celluloid film Southern
California is one of the few places in
America with independent telephone
companies not part of the giant Bell
monopoly that handled the rest of the
country well behind us is a step-by-step
system and it's a relative of the
telephone systems that were used in most
of Southern California the Bell System
didn't have as much of monopoly there as
I dial a number various elements of the
step connect me through the system from
start to finish and that's work out the
name step by step as I finish dialing
the call will connect
and it can be answered now in the step
system it doesn't have what's called far
end supervision and that means that the
called party can hang up and pick up
again as many times as they want and the
call won't disconnect but if the calling
party hangs up the called party will get
hit with dial tone right away because
the system doesn't know whether I've
been hung up on or whether I just picked
up the phone so in Hollywood where all
the movies were being written and filmed
their experience on the telephone was
actually different from most of the rest
of America and the world which let's be
honest is kind of like so many other
things in Hollywood the bottom line is
the folks making the movies really did
get a dial tone
when they were hung up on at least
sometimes so they put that in their
films or they picked whichever option
worked best for the scene if it's still
happening when a character uses a cell
phone though that's just lazy thank you
to all the team at Seattle's wonderful
Museum of communication you can check
out their YouTube channel over here or
pull down the description for a link to
the museum and to see their opening
hours and a list of all the incredible
equipment they've got here